(male announcer)
Today on Judge Jessie,
Judge Jessie turns up the heat.
You signed a piece of paper.
He gave you the snake.
Then you bring a snake
into the home
with two small Chihuahuas.
I had not been made aware
that the snake
would get rid of its skin,
and then the sprinklers
came down with the snakeskin,
ruined my carpet.
(Jessie)
What--what set off
the sprinklers?
Unrelated popcorn fire,
Your Honor.
(announcer)
Judge Jessie.
As a police officer,
he defended the streets.
As a trial lawyer...
Objection!
(announcer)
He fought for the truth.
As a black belt...
[grunting]
(announcer)
He mastered discipline.
As a carpenter,
he learned the value
of craftsmanship.
As a surgeon,
he mastered a cool head.
As a crack ho,
he learned to go days
without sleep.
And as an announcer,
he does the voice-over
on this show.
Coming up on Judge Jessie...
Mr. Simmons, before you speak,
I know from experience
that the police have completely
mishandled your case,
and there is legal precedent
for you to win,
and any good defense attorney
would have told you that.
I also know that obviously the
place where you hurt your back
wasn't structurally
up to code, Mr. Oyama.
And furthermore,
as a sensei,
you should know a man
of his skill set
cannot do a Mike Yaki.
You should know that.
Obviously, I can tell
by looking at your alignment
that you've herniated a disc
someplace in your L4 or your L5.
I'm finding for the plaintiff
not $2,500,
$2,700, Mr. Oyama.
Thank you, Your Honor.
You're quite welcome.
(announcer)
Judge Jessie.
Dusty, can I suck your dick?